if you're trying to get your YouTube
channel launched today's video talks
about the top five mistakes that new
youtubers make when launching their
channel and how to stop sucking on
camera so I got a question for one of my
YouTube viewers Patricia love you guys
who wrote in to say hey Evan I have a
problem with my videos actually several
problems welcome to the club but the one
that I'm concerned about the most is
that I think they're too dull boring and
repetitive I want to get people's
attention but I can't do it by saying
the same thing again and again what
would you recommend to shake up a little
bit more about my videos thanks for this
video it helped a lot this is a
fantastic question and I think every
youtuber struggles on their journey to
eventually achieving success and I've
definitely learned a lot on my journey
from starting with nothing to having
millions of views on my channel I'm
going to share with you the five
mistakes that most newbie youtubers make
and how you can avoid sucking on camera
so number one is having no passion so
many new youtubers have zero passion and
emotion in their videos and I get why
you do it you know you're nervous in
front of the camera here you're not used
to speaking to a screen you don't have
an audience in front of you that you can
get energy from you also might be trying
to remember the script and say exactly
the words that you want to say and get
exactly the message out that you want to
get out and the end result is a super
boring video I remember one of my first
videos let's link it up here was on Walt
Disney and I had a professional video
crew come in and I had a script that I
memorized that I wanted to be perfect
and and it looked great the setup was
perfect but because I was so nervous
because I was just speaking to a camera
because I wanted to get the exact words
out my delivery sucked and I would use
passionate words with no passion I would
say things like to learn from Walt
Disney you need to make sure that you
follow your passion so boring right so
you've got to tap into your passion
you've got to stop boring about scene
exact words exactly as you wrote them
down and instead let the emotion come
through and have more passion every
video that you create how you say
something is equally as important as
what you're saying
so inject more passion into your videos
number two is repeating yourself if you
watch a lot of newbie youtubers in their
videos are saying the same thing over
and over and over again and and maybe
finding three different ways to say the
exact same message you need to practice
getting your message to be concise one
exercise that really helped me that my
media coach gave me is to practice doing
one-minute Mondays where basically I had
to deliver a message and a story and
something impactful in under two minutes
and do that every single week on my
channel and at first it was really hard
I couldn't get anything out in under two
minutes and I thought I have so much to
say I have so many stories I want to get
it out there but when I look back on my
old videos I realized I just kept saying
the same thing over and over and over
again and using different words so
practice your own version of a
one-minute Monday so you can get concise
thinking and execution of your ideas
number three is summarizing and not
being specific a lot of newbie youtubers
are not great storytellers they're
telling their story they're explaining
something that was traumatic in their
life or life-changing that happened
before and you just give the high level
summary instead of making me feel like
I'm a part of the story this is
something I had a huge problem with
myself as I was trying to develop my
channel and get better as a speaker I
would talk about a major problem I had
and say and that was a really tough
period in my life and so I decided I
really had to turn things around I would
give very few details and wasn't very
specific at all where instead it's
better to talk about fewer points but go
deeper on them if you're talking about a
time in your life where you are really
struggling take me there
make it feel like I'm sitting next to
you on the couch watching it happen tell
me about how you were crying and how the
the tears were coming out of your eyes
and your nose and tell me about how your
mother came and put her hand on your
shoulder and told you that everything
was going to be okay tell me what you
were thinking feeling acting tell me
about it
make me again feel like I am right
they're watching with you instead of
being up here where I'm disconnected and
I don't really understand what's going
on
so stop summarizing and start being
specific number four is not
personalizing your videos wherever
possible you want to be able to tell a
personal story to help bring your point
home your story not only helps people
connect to you more but also helps drive
your point home so in my first point I
was talking about not having passion I
shared an example but my first Disney
video that you can go back and click on
in my second point about repeating
yourself I shared an example about how I
kept repeating myself and used a
one-minute Monday exercise that helped
me get through so try to add a personal
story or anecdote to every single video
that you make you'll often find that the
best stories are the ones that make you
vulnerable where you're talking about
real problems that you have I've made
videos talking about my divorce my hair
loss my weight gain as struggles that I
faced when I was growing my business I
talked about how I was making $300 a
month barely able to survive feeling
totally worthless feeling totally
helpless feeling like I added no value
to the world and I didn't know what to
do with my life
and that can be really hard to do
because in general you want to present a
positive picture when you go out and you
meet people and they ask you how you are
that the default answer is I'm fine
we're really maybe you're not so fine
and if you look at the top youtubers
they're willing to share their
vulnerabilities they're willing to share
their stories and they're willing to be
naked figuratively in front of the
camera so start sharing and start
getting more personalized number 5 is
your videos are important enough my
agent liked to tell me when we first
started working together that my videos
they weren't important enough he always
used to say I had to up the stakes every
time I got off a call with him when he
reviewed my videos he said up the stakes
up the ante make it more important and
it's true if your videos are more
important if you go in with the
intention of the videos being important
then that makes a quality that much
better here
exercise that I like to do before I get
on camera I imagine someone who's having
a problem who's going through something
really important in their life and who
needs help
I imagine that my video is the last
thing that they're going to watch before
they make this all-important decision if
a video is talking about self-confidence
for example I might imagine somebody
who's just about to jump off a bridge
and kill themselves and my video is the
last thing that they are going to watch
before they make that super important
life decision that makes me feel like
the video that I'm about to create is
more important and when I feel like it's
more important than I'm going to project
that importance on to you now the
reality is it's not going to be that
important for most people but it will be
that important for some people and
unless you project yourself with the
confidence and with that important stake
in mind you're not going to hit those
people I do videos helping entrepreneurs
but I've had people who wrote to me
saying Evan your videos have saved my
life that's important and so you need to
approach your videos with that same
level of importance the next time you
step in front of the camera you want to
be thinking the video that I'm making
right now has the ability to change or
save somebody's life make your videos
more important start to up the ante and
people will start to care a lot more and
my sixth bonus tip is actually care I
think it's by default for most youtubers
that you care about your audience you
care about what you're doing I feel the
love from patricia's , that she's
genuinely trying to make videos that
people will care about some youtubers
don't care they're just trying to put
videos up there to try to make a lot of
money they're trying to monetize who
advertise in ourselves some affiliate
programs if you don't actually care
about your audience then there's no way
that they're actually going to care
about you so those are my five plus one
tips on the mistakes that most beginners
make on how to stop sucking on camera
and of course remember to continue to
believe for those are you watching if
you like this video you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for tuning in and I'll
see you soon
South improvement books are like Fitness
books they never work on their own what
you need is a trainer that's ever get
the newsletter
you